assis au premier rang ils sont venus
apporter leur soutien à la maire
sortante de plaisir jean michel fourgous
pierre bédier gérard larcher les poids
lourds politiques du département ont pu
notamment assisté à la présentation
officielle de l'équipe de campagne de
joséphine coleman ce berger put vie
comme plaisir comme d'autres communes
c'est un élément du puzzle qui fait la
république et puis je trouve qu'une
action de jeu le défi comme le berger
qui dépasse d'ailleurs tous les
engagements politiques je suis là comme
ami et pour porter témoignage comme
sénateur de son action pour cette
deuxième campagne des municipales en
tant que tête de liste la maire sortant
a choisi de largement renouvelé ses
colistiers un mélange d'anciens et de
plus jeunes pour insuffler une nouvelle
dynamique
on sent une vraie énergie une vraie
volonté ya une vraie joie de vivre comme
ça je peux vous dire et beaucoup
d'enthousiasmé ya plus de 50% qui est
renouvelée mais on a l'équipe qui est
temps qu'elle a en place depuis 2014 et
certains même depuis bien avant et je
dis toujours on a tellement travaillé
beaucoup travaillé que on se demande
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas continuer
dans cette aventure
chacun leur tour les trente neuf
colistiers ont pris la parole durant la
soirée une présentation express qui
semble avoir convaincu la centaine de
personnes présentes
j'ai l'impression que l'équipe est très
sympathique que ça va bien se passer je
l'espère
mais là pour six ans donc
les jeunes d'apprendre de voir et
ça semble être une bonne équipe je suis
toujours un wait and see il ya une
équipe qui visiblement a l'air de bien
s'entendre et qui qui a l'air d'avoir
vraiment envie d'avancer
le programme de la liste plaisir avant
ce sera communiqué aux habitants dans
une semaine
ville nature ville humaine ville
responsable et ville entreprenante sont
les quatre axes majeurs de joséphine
coleman ce berger il y a 6 ans l'édile
avait remporté l'élection dès le premier
tour avec plus de 58% des suffrages
une performance qu'elle a avoué vouloir
renouveler le 15 mars prochain elle sera
alors opposé à trois autres listes